من جهته حتى وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتر كوليبا دول مجموعه اسيان على اتخاذ
جميع الاجراءات الممكنه لمنع روسيا من
ممارسه ما وصفها بالاعيب الجوع ما يتعلق
باتفاق تصدير شحنات الحبوب الاوكرانيه من
البحر الاسود
لمنع روسيا من ممارسه الاعب الجوع مع
العالم يجب ابقاء ممر تصدير الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه
وروسيا ينبغي ان لا تستخدم هذا الممر
كورقه ابتزاز او نقطه استغلال في علاقاتها
الدوليه
ونائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي قد اكدوا خلال
اجتماع في جناز التزام الطرفين بتطبيق
اتفاق تصدير الاسمده الروسيه الاساسيه
لمكافحه الازمه الغذائيه نقش الاجتماع
العوائق التي تعترض صادرات الاسمده
والحبوب الروسيه والقبيان صادر عن الامم
المتحده وجاء في بيان صدر في ختام
الاجتماع ان المشاركين شددوا على ان
العالم لا يمكنه ان يسمح لتحول المشاكل
العالميه للحصول على الاسمده الى نقص
غذائي
قال البيان ان ممثلي الامم المتحده
المشاركين في هذه المفاوضات تحدث عن
المبادرات المتخذه لتسهيل دفع ثمن الحبوب
والاسمده ورسوم تامينها ووصولها الى موانئ
الاتحاد الاوروبي